[Music]
hey guys I want them to bring you part
two of my medical journey when I made
part 1 talking about college in medical
school
I asked if you wanted to see the rest of
my journey talking about residency
social media traditional media and you
seem to really want it so here we go
let's get started I'm gonna talk about
everything from medical school on I
think a good place to jump in here would
be to talk about the match process I
know that gives people a lot of anxiety
when we talk about the match because
it's complicated it's a major life
moment that decides where you're gonna
be for the next few years and I totally
understand that and especially there's a
lot of changes going on with the current
match system because the do match and
the MD match are actually combining and
are gonna become one match in 2020 so
that brings an extra layer of anxiety
along with it when I was going through
the match process you had to decide if
you're gonna forego the deal match and
go straight to the MD match or you can
participate in both matches actually
I've seen some people do that they would
pick a couple of their favorite do
programs and if they didn't get into
those then they would automatically be
pushed over into the MD match I was
going only for the do match I didn't
want to do the MD match because I really
believe in the do philosophy I wanted to
train under osteopathic physicians and
continue honing my do skills not only do
I believe in the philosophy of treating
a patient as a whole and everything else
that comes along with being an osteopath
but also doing the osteopathic
manipulation I've seen some great
results with my patients low risk tool
that I have in my tool built that I can
use in addition to medicines and surgery
I interviewed at probably it was a large
amount most people don't interview it in
as many places as I did but I wanted to
get a good picture of what it was like
in each of these hospitals so I think I
interviewed at a total of maybe 12 to 15
different hospitals I applied to
probably thirty places I went as far as
interviewing in places like Florida just
because I wanted to see how different
the healthcare system was within Florida
within New York New Jersey Long Island
even
and I found that my top two choices that
I really enjoyed for family medicine
were overlooked medical center and
Jamaica Hospital in Queens New York what
really turned the tide for me was that
an overlooked Medical Center the
residents got along really well and in
residency programs it's not unusual to
see bickering between residents
especially because it's such a stressful
time in your life you think about how
many hours you're committing to work
these people essentially become your
family so it's really important that you
get along with your co residents because
you're gonna be spending a lot a lot of
time with them I saw the relationship
between the residents I saw that they
were being true they weren't putting on
a show during interview day and when you
go on some of your interviews if you're
going through this process you're gonna
see a lot of fake stuff happen you're
gonna see program directors you're gonna
see residents you're gonna see
secretaries you're gonna put on shows
for you and I understand that if you're
trying to make a good impression on
somebody you're gonna put your best foot
forward but what was nice an overlook I
saw that the residents weren't putting
on a show they were honest they really
were friends you could see that even
when you walked away from the interview
process you were able to see that they
were really friends they were talking
they were making plans to hang out plus
overlock does a really great job at
allowing you to hang out with the
residents even go for lunch with some of
the residents something that I do
encourage everybody to take advantage of
if they're considering choosing a
specific residency program is doing
something called the second look a
second look is basically when you come
in on an on interview day and shadow one
of the residents around for the day to
see what their daily duties are like
definitely take advantage of this number
one you get to see what the program is
like when they're not putting their best
foot forward when there may be an
incident where they might where
something might go wrong and you get to
see what it's like and how they handle
those situations funny enough I think
that I did my second look for overlook
on Christmas either Christmas or maybe
Christmas Eve so you would think right
you're going into a residency program
where
residents are working a major holiday
and you would think they would all be
unhappy right because it's major holiday
they're away from their families none of
that I sat in on rounds I went into the
hospital with them I got to see what
they did on a regular basis on a given
day even on a day like Christmas or
Christmas Eve whatever the holiday was
and guess what they had great attitudes
they all got along very well and most
importantly they were humble in medicine
things change all the time we'll make
one recommendation only to change it
back to the previous recommendation a
few years later this happens we've seen
this with coffee in the 80s we were
saying coffee gives you pancreatic
cancer in 2017 studies are saying it
makes you live longer I think a good
doctor is a good skeptic of themselves
that's why I always highlight that a
good doctor should never be scared to
say I don't know and in fact say that
the reason that I know this information
is because it's based on the best
information available to me now but it
may change in the future we have to come
with that kind of open mind when we're
treating our patients and that's the
exact type of personality and leadership
that I saw an overlock Medical Center I
saw dr. tribuna who's my program
director I saw dr. divine talk about
those things I saw that leadership
happen amongst the residents and I said
this is a place where I want to Train
these are the type of residents and
leadership I want to surround myself
with they were amazing with their
bedside manner
they were humble they knew what their
limitations were these are definitely
characteristics that I wanted to carry
on as a physician myself after leaving
my second look and doing the ranking
process I ranked Overlook Medical Center
as my first choice Jamaica Hospital as
my second choice oh let me get into the
interview portion out of out of some of
these hospitals because this this gets
funny and I don't want this to throw you
in the previous video I talked about
what it means to have a good interview
it's all about being yourself it's all
about telling your story and it's all
about vocalizing your story and your
answers to yourself before you go in for
that interview some of these interviews
and I'm not going to name the programs
because I don't want a badmouth anybody
but they get just incredibly strange
strange is the right word for because
they ask really weird questions I
remember a doctor at a New Jersey
hospital asking me what if I was a
vegetable what vegetable would I be or
if I was a candy what candy would I be
and then I remember in one hospital in
Long Island one of the directors
actually wasn't even a director he was
the behavioral psychologist for that
program asking me this series of
questions and it was really strange he
told me pick a person that you think
knows you best and think about that
person and then he said now answer these
questions as if you're that person let's
say I said my friend Marc was my
favorite was the person that knew me
best
what would Marc say is Mike's biggest
strength
aka my strength and then I had to answer
and then he said what would Marc say you
know Mike's a great guy but what's his
biggest weakness and he framed the whole
interview as if he was interviewing Marc
not myself this may be a psychological
interesting way of interviewing somebody
but it's not human and I didn't like
that I don't like when you try and play
psychological mind games during an
interview that's not what it's supposed
to be about it's supposed to be about a
one-on-one human connection I never
liked those types of questions when
someone asks you them answer them openly
answer them honestly be human don't be
afraid to talk about your faults I did
all those interviews I picked to
overlook as my number one choice I was
very nervous wondering where I where I
would end up because you are gonna spend
the next three years of your life at
that place and I know some people that
go into very very competitive
specialties some of them are competitive
because there's only you know single
number of spots in a state so they apply
all across the country and they don't
know if next for the next three to five
years they're gonna be in California in
New York in Florida and Texas you will
see tears on match day you will see
smiles on match day it's a very very
tedious unique process that applies to
the
medical journey now on my matchday I was
doing rotations in Trinity's Hospital in
New Jersey for my internal medicine sub
I and a sub I is basically
sub-internship
you're basically the intern which is
your first year of residency you're
basically the interns assistant and you
get to do a lot of the things that the
average third-year medical student can't
do and I was doing that and I got an
email on my phone saying that I
successfully matched with overlooked
Medical Center I was so excited I mean
to get your number one choice in
whatever specialty you're going for is
amazing I remember dr. tribunal leaving
me a very kind voicemail welcoming me to
the program telling me how they're very
excited to have me and something that I
really like that he said and I still
can't really get comfortable doing is he
said from now on it's not dr. tribuna
it's Joe and he wanted to call him by
his first name and I couldn't get used
to that I was there for three years
every day that I would see him I would
say doctor Tribune out of respect and he
would say Mike Joe it's Joe and you try
and get me to call him Joe he does that
with all his residents the nicest
program director ever smart probably the
best I'm comfortable saying that the
best bedside manner I've seen in a
physician
we talked afterwards on the phone both
were really excited and it was time to
start my medical journey I graduated
boom I'm a doctor I got my do degree and
I had basically a month to relax before
residency started and I want to urge all
of you if you have some time off before
your residency starts please enjoy it go
party go explore vacation whatever you
need to do to enjoy yourself please do
it and I'm not saying that because
residency is a horrible time in your
life but I will tell you it is a
stressful time there's going to be an
insane time commitment that you're gonna
have to dedicate to the program and it's
needed you need to commit that much time
in order to have a solid foundation for
your medical learning I went on some
vacations during that time so when I
came into residency I was fresh that's
what you want to do you want to come in
fresh eager ready to learn the last
thing you want to do
is overwhelm yourself with research or
something and then come in completely
burned out into a place where the
burnout rate is really high on its own
now you're going into residency and
you're wondering what should I do so
that I learned the most or that I'm
prepared the most nothing yes you can
read some books you can look over some
manuals and have some handouts in your
pockets in your white coat but nothing
is gonna prepare you for what you're
gonna experience in residency I don't
mean to sound dire it's not that crazy
and dangerous but residency's tricky
you're gonna be interacting with a lot
of different people nurses doctors a
maze janitorial staff phlebotomist s--
patients patients family members
insurance companies I mean the amount of
people you communicate with on a daily
basis is gonna be amazing you're not
gonna know how to handle everything you
have to not be afraid to ask questions
that's the number one thing in residency
if you're confident about something
great but if you're the slightest bit
unsure either a look it up or B ask a
senior for advice because the last thing
you want to do is hurt a patient hurt a
patient's family member because you're
too proud to confirm your knowledge I
despise that about some people that are
what we call Cowboys in the field they
think that day read something somewhere
on the internet now they know everything
about the subject and they're gonna
write all these orders put in all these
medications without double-checking I
double-checked everything even things
that was somewhat comfortable with I
asked the senior to make sure that they
saw me do the procedure so let me do the
auto right so I was treating the
patients of the best of my ability
obviously as you get more comfortable
throughout your time in residency you'll
be doing that less and less and you're
going to be teaching more and more when
residency first started my first two
months were on the surgical floor I was
basically an acting surgery resident and
what's interesting about Overlook
Medical Center is that not only our
Overlook residents they're doing surgery
but also Columbia residents are doing
surgery there and that's why the fun
fact dr. oz actually did some of his
trained
medical center as part of this residency
and basically what happens is as an
intern you get partnered up with a
senior Columbia resident and they
basically teach you the ropes
allow you to carry the pager scrub it
into some operations basically jump in
in the first week and you're taking care
of patients someone's having high blood
pressure
someone's becoming tachycardic meaning
their hearts beating fast
Brady Karthik the other way their heart
is beating really slow you're the one
that's getting paged first you're the
one responsible and while I was happy to
have that responsibility I was also
nervous and it's okay to be nervous
nervous energy can be good energy if
it's not chronic meaning it doesn't
happen over a long period of time you
need to embrace that energy and say this
energy this anxiety is preparing me to
take on this challenge of taking on
these pages these patients and all of
that initially when I got some of those
pages I may have been a little too
nervous and maybe ask my seniors for too
much help but just because I wasn't
confident especially because during my
fourth year I did a lot of family
medicine rotations where you don't do a
lot of surgery and I was doing that
because I wanted to figure out where I
wanted to end up in terms of my
residency but because that I didn't have
a lot of surgical experience so I relied
very heavily on the Columbia surgical
residents to help me out but then as the
week's went by I became more and more
comfortable in managing the patients I
became more and more comfortable
answering pages and it's really
important because when you're on call
it's the middle of the night you get a
page you have to answer it your senior
is likely scrubbed in in the middle of
the night in an intense surgery and so
is the attending so you don't really
have anyone to go for answers unless
it's obviously a dire emergency so you
get very good at using some of the
hospital resources like up-to-date which
is basically a system that we look for
for evidence-based medicine information
for example if I saw a patient that was
post surgically having a fever
you can go on up to date search
post-surgical fever and get some
information about it that can help guide
your work up your treatment and so on so
forth this is where it's probably really
important to mention that during med
school I started an Instagram account
and initially it was dr. Mikey or
something it was like dr underscore mike
with like three e's or something like
that
because i wanted to show what it was
like to be just an ordinary medical
student nothing special but be able to
enjoy your life be able to have a
balance between exercise education
social life going out enjoying nice
events but still doing well in school
because i feel there exists a stigma and
i really think it's a stigma that if you
go into medical school you have to give
up your life myth busted that is
complete BS everybody needs to study
very hard in medical school but it
doesn't mean that you have to give up
your life you could study hard you can
study smart and you could do very well
while still enjoying your life so what i
was doing i was sort of doing a what was
popular back then a lot of those at
myspace it came after myspace but it was
one of those it was like not a blog it
was xanga basically what I was doing was
showing my life through the internet I
was living my life through the internet
and I was blocking this was a new thing
that people were doing in the mid to
early 2000s xanga live journal these
were popular blogging sites but I was
like I want to do that on Instagram I
want to do a photo blog of my life so I
took selfies of me in the operating room
I took selfies with my dog I took
selfies with my dad at fancy events and
throughout New York City and people
really enjoyed what I was doing
so I build up a pretty significant
following for the average person
somewhere twenty thirty thousand
followers going into residency it was a
running joke during my intern year that
people that knew me well they would make
jokes like oh dr. mike has a lot of
followers on Instagram with his twenty
thousand he was a celebrity
and look we had fun with it the nurses
had fun with it my coal residents had
fun with it occasionally they would
catch one of their friends following me
and we would tease them about it but
whatever it was all in good fun I
thought it was something useful that I
was doing showing but you know medical
students what it was like to be a doctor
maybe people that just enjoyed medicine
and I thought that in the future maybe
this could be of some value I didn't
know exactly how he could be a value but
I thought that it was nice that I can
communicate with thousands of people at
home just how I do with everybody in my
everyday life so despite calls from some
people saying that taking selfies was
unprofessional or being on social media
was unprofessional
I saw a greater use for it in the future
so I left it
it didn't take up much time I would take
a selfie here and there most people
never saw me take a selfie
my dad didn't even know I had social
media because prior to this I never even
had Twitter or Instagram or any of this
stuff I don't think I ever overstepped
the line and gave an unrealistic view of
what I was doing I think that when you
saw me smiling in those pictures I
wasn't just smiling for the pictures I
was smiling with my residents a few
moments before that I worked really hard
intern years crazy
I worked 36-hour shifts when you're the
ICU you're working six days a week on
call every other day meaning that when
you're on call not only do you come in
at 4:35 a.m. but you go home at 9 p.m.
just think about how little time that
leaves for you to sleep or take care of
yourself it's a really grueling schedule
during that month you learn a lot you do
that rotation I believe two times in the
first year at least from my program boom
I'm in my second year and you get four
weeks off I think this is a requirement
you get four weeks off a year during
your residency and during my first year
I didn't really have vacations towards
the tail-end of that residency year so I
did my first week of vacation in August
September of my second year and guess
what I'm on vacation
I'm in Florida and all of a sudden one
of my buddies texted me
and he said hey man you're on BuzzFeed
and I'm like oh man that's really cool
because while I've done some little news
articles here and there I've done some
scientific publications I've never had
something as big as BuzzFeed mention me
and I was like oh that's cool I read the
story it wasn't anything about my
medical accomplishments it was hot
doctor and husky and I was like oh
that's nice like awesome compliment
pretty exciting I didn't think anything
would come from it and then as the day
went on I started getting more and more
texts from people not only about
BuzzFeed now now elite daily then
Huffington Post and then AOL calm then
time then Cosmo then glamour and all of
a sudden my inbox starts imploding I
mean everybody's emailing me that week
Ellen DeGeneres people Steve Harvey
people everybody is saying if you do our
show you can do our show but you can't
do their show you if you come on Fox you
can't do CBS by the way I don't remember
exactly who said what but this was all
being said and I'm a resident I know
nothing about media I have no
representation I have no guides I don't
even know anyone in the industry really
I always faced with a choice because I'm
a professional and I'm going into a
professional field and I had to decide
do you embrace this hot topic sorry this
hot doctor topic as something that you
want to go in front of millions of
people on television and talk about as
if it's something you truly care about I
didn't really care that people are
calling me hot doctor but what I did
care was that suddenly millions of
people were interested to listen to me
and I viewed that as an opportunity
honestly was insane
I gained 750,000 followers in those two
weeks my phone was just I had to turn
off notifications for the first time in
my life I've never had to do that for
anything because so many things were
coming in I was answering news agencies
at the time and it's funny because I was
on vacation and wasn't able to do a lot
of the news stuff till the following
week I shout to them the following week
said sorry it's been so crazy I would
like to come on this week they were like
know you're old news man like you you
were on last week we think we talked
about you last week this week we have no
use for you and I realized how cutthroat
the industry was very quickly now I'm
getting these opportunities my Instagram
is exploding what I felt like I had to
do with social media was find a positive
outlet for it
how can I get people that are watching
nonsense Kim Kardashian videos and
listening to percocet Molly percocet how
can I get those people to watch my
content where we can have some fun I'll
dance like I'm a loser
whatever have some fun get some laughs
but also learn something in the process
I can talk about percocet Molly percocet
and dance to it but I can explain to you
what percocet Molly percocet are I try
to find a balance between social media
and learning how could we make those two
things coexist from that moment that was
in 2015 its January 2018 now a lot has
transpired I started a YouTube channel
that's how you're watching me now I've
done a lot of television my social media
has sort of transformed the outside of
just Instagram it's on Facebook Twitter
even I do some little snapchat here and
there I do see a lot of people asking
questions and making statements about
how I am a doctor but yet I am also a
marketer because I do do advertisements
on my social media and some of them say
oh this isn't medically ethical for you
to be a good marketer and a doctor those
two things cannot coexist I understand
where that sentiment comes from I see
the TV doctors that are selling nonsense
and compromising their medical ethics I
totally understand that and I agree with
you to a point when I do an
advertisement for let's say a watch
company I don't think that compromises
my medical ethics because when I
introspectively look at that me
recommending to wear watch or not even
recommending to wear watch me just
saying I like this watch or I wear this
watch has no impact on our
doctor-patient relationship another
place where I think that marketing can
even be good for medicine is that when I
do an ad for let's say Charmin reached
out to me once and I did an ad for
Charmin they wanted me to take a picture
in front of their Charmin on the Govan
where people go take poops literally on
the street it's pretty funny but it's
part of their advertising they wanted me
to take a picture of that and show that
to my Instagram community I wanted to
take the picture but I also wanted to
use this opportunity to educate you at
home and talk about the different signs
and symptoms that you should look out
for that might mean something serious or
warrant further evaluation so I told
them yes I'll take a picture from the
truck but I'm gonna tell people to look
at their poop and look at the different
changes in their poops that should
require them to go see a doctor so I did
two things in that I advertised what
they needed me to advertise I made money
that I can use for this YouTube channel
to educate you and continue doing what I
do to make money for myself to feed my
family to feed myself and pay off my
student loans and I was able to get some
education across again I only do
advertising for companies that I believe
in that I would actually use I wouldn't
you know advertise some crazy creepy
products that I've been pitched in the
past I mean I've been pitched just the
nuttiest things in the world obviously
I've gotten seven-figure offers from
vitamin supplement companies that want
me to say this is the next best thing
this is what's gonna cure what ails you
this is this is the solution I will
never do that why because as a doctor I
want proof that it works and if it works
I'll recommend that as a doctor I don't
need to be paid to do it that's my job
I'm already paid to do that I really
work hard to make sure that the things
that I do advertise do not cross those
medical lines lines sometimes do get
blurry but again I will always make my
best effort to make sure I never cross
that because I'm a doctor first well I'm
a human first but I'm a doctor second
and that's what's most important to me
your health our trust that we form
between each other is really important
to me and I think that when you're our
social media personality that trust is
even more important I do have some more
stuff to talk about doing television I
do a lot of TV now Good Morning America
the doctor's Show Rachael Ray and that's
a whole different animal on its own and
I'm also learning that process so if you
want to know more about that process and
how I do it and what I do and what my
journeys been like
comment below give this video alike and
continue supporting good creators
because that's what it's about it's
about having a community where we're all
sharing our experiences those who are
good storytellers continue being heard
and I really appreciate what you guys do
by watching my channel sharing my
channel liking and commenting I try to
make a really serious effort to not only
like and heart everybody's comments but
also jump in and reply as much as I can
I know that some of you have seen that
and they may not be you know paragraph
replies but again remember I am a doctor
I am bouncing around from place to place
so I do try my best as always guys
thanks for watching stay happy and
healthy I didn't move my chair did I
this sound isn't annoying water please
[Music]